police say adam lanza used a bushmaster
ar-15 style rifle to kill 20 small
children and six adults at sandy hook
elementary school in 2012.
two years later some of the victims
families decided to sue remington the
maker of the bushmaster
they were told they had no chance of
winning i could never tell you i thought
i'd see this day
and it's not going to bring mary back
it's not going to bring any of these
kids back
but
the cost of business
is going to go up substantially
the 73 million dollar settlement between
remington one of the oldest gun
manufacturers in the united states and
some of the families is the first of its
kind in this country the deal means
remington won't go on trial in september
on charges its business practices
contributed to the massacre today marks
an inflection point
when our duty of care to our children as
a society finally supersedes
the bottom line of an industry
that made such an atrocity as sandy hook
possible to begin with that
accountability means the families will
get to make public internal company
documents showing just how remington
marketed bushmasters to the public
especially to socially insecure young
men
and the linchpin of this settlement is
that it allows these families
the rights to share the information as
to what they learned
remington had fought the lawsuit
claiming a 2005 federal law did not hold
it and other gun manufacturers liable
for how their products were used no
matter
how tragic no matter how much
we wish those children and their
teachers
were not lost and their families had not
suffered
the law needs to be applied
dispassionately the sandy hook family
say the time for being dispassionate is
over i made a very early promise to do
everything in my power to honor his
short life this lawsuit has been part of
that promise
the closest i get to him now is by
kissing his urn every night
telling him i love him and i miss him
but i made him a promise and i'll keep
working to deliver that promise for the
rest of my life
more than nine years and two months
after sandy hook a hard-fought
accountability that still cannot erase
the worst of losses ruslan jordan al
jazeera washington